when you're in an ad do you voice an
opinion on the ad or do you just do
oh you do always do they welcome that
opinion no
no but i mean i know better than they do
that is the truth yes
and i'm experienced and i need to help
them sometimes
grammar is often bad
she really doesn't want to listen to
myself
i do we'll get notes we'll get notes
later
because miriam you were the voice of a
period weren't you a menstrual period
sorry my mistake
and as an actress how did you find that
voice
well you always go to the text
first yes and the text was
you didn't expect to find me on your
holidays
so i thought well
that's got to be a naughty school girl
so
i i went um
you didn't expect to find me on your
holidays did you
[Music]
beautiful what were you selling
standards
it was um it was for a sanitary
protection
yeah sanitary protection yeah sales went
up
by imagine yes i i have actually got a
menstrual story for you if you like
off you go mary margulis did i tell you
last time about when i did an
audition for crossroads no i didn't
think so well
for those of you who may remember
crossroads was a
a soap opera yeah which took place in
birmingham and i went for the uh
for the audition and um i'm pouring this
all over myself it's rather exciting
and as i was waiting for my turn to
to do to do the audition my period
started
and i thought period
period don't you call it
no i just said i'm on the rag
[Applause]
yes how are you doing dominick you're
doing that yeah
all good there yeah okay pretty
comfortable
so meanwhile back in birmingham miriam
just had her period so
i went i went to the ladies room and in
those days
there was a long box on the wall dr
southall sanitary towels and you put in
two
two pennies and pulled the little drawer
and got out the carton am i right you
remember all this summer
and um people applauding oh yes
so i put in my two p pulled out the
little drawer
and it snapped back with my finger in it
so it was really painful it tore great
gash in my finger which was ex so sore
bleeding all over the place i managed to
pull open the draw and
extract my finger i rushed into the loo
and fixed myself up came out again
and went in and started to read
for the audition and i noticed
the script was covered in blood
and the people i was auditioning for
noticed it too
and they looked and i i saw them looking
and i said oh i i'm so
sorry you see my period
did you get the job i did it you got the
job
yay now this is 31st studio album
something like that no wow and what's
great is listening to these songs it's
you and bernie taupin sort of at the top
of your game
well it's the most piano orientated
record i've ever made and it's a very
simple album
and i don't really see the point of
making a record if you don't try and
make it better
um i've been making records since 1969
and i made a lot of records
um and this one is one of my favorites
um
because i think we've come a step
further i'm singing better i'm playing
better
it's a very relaxed album and so i'm
very happy with it and
you know i'm sure judy would say that
she goes into every part hoping to make
a better performance than the last one
there's no point in carrying on
otherwise
um just for the sake of it i mean they
want record company who are here tonight
[__]
[Applause]
i don't mean that they're a very good
wreck on it but you know it's been
successful
they wanted me to make christmas albums
and you know
cover albums motown records but that is
so silly you know
i'll leave that to rod stewart and
people
did i say that okay yes have you said
that his album's doing much better than
mine
[__]
the ministry of defense this and this is
this is
down to you because obviously you have a
particular fan base
the ministry of defense they've released
the latest bunch of x-files featuring a
various sightings
by members of the public so they heard
uh you were on the show
uh they were very keen to help so uh how
did the ministry of defense
here what department of military defense
goes you'll never guess is on norton
oh you rang themselves they did they
didn't hear them
they've got their newly released ufo
files but uh presumably
they just wanted people to be aware of
some of these people
and now some of this is
very very frightening i'll warn you now
now a plymouth woman reported a sighting
that occurred when she went downstairs
in the night
to refill the hot water bottles
as you do do you though you fill them
you're warm you go to sleep you wake up
they're cold but now you're warm in bed
you kick them out
you don't refill them problem is that
hot water bottles just aren't as good as
they were great
i mean you know i blame the moon
landings
they've got that all the search money
into the wrong place that's what's
happening
with plymouth just being pilloried by
you because of the moon landing
anyway thank god he's here the the
report said
report said she saw a brownie orange
object over her
house now she also drew a picture
are you ready here's the picture
[Laughter]
you think a brown object heading towards
the house that's just the kids from the
estate throwing [__] at her window
it's the mad woman refilling the bottles
doesn't make you think when you look at
this why are these objects always seen
by people who can't
draw here's our ufo as spotted near
a bread solar hill top in darby
that's just somebody's pants isn't it
but my favorite alien one is this one
cited in
west london
alien half banana
but now this is extraordinary this is a
letter
from these top secret files now um where
is it now i can show you
that's the the actual writing of the
letter
but uh this letter we don't have any
names to these people
right so uh dear sirs your first
reaction to this letter
will be one of full disbelief however
let me assure you i am neither
insane or as charlatan as the facts will
prove and if you've got to put that in
the first line of a letter
chances are you're insane and a
charlotte there you go
now it starts off when it's sort of mad
but sane enough
during world war ii as i'm sure you're
aware a crashed ufo was recovered by the
military somewhere in this country
i should like to know the exact date and
location of this event
fair enough okay you know i don't know
this stuff maybe a ufo landed that you
know everybody knows about but she
doesn't
she wants to know where it landed it is
possible
this was [__] lock warren uh
right this that's okay [__] lock warren
uh the location of which as
yet unable to discover there are several
options uh
whistman's wood by west start devon
between garrow point and blackstone
point devon the norfolk coast or wenlock
edge
in fact the name [__] luck warren could
be
quite wrong it just came into my mind
one morning from whence i know not
so it's like you know you're going to be
your tom tom for a long time
with just names you've made up i want to
go to
[__] luck warren
now the thing is why does she want to
know well here we know that
the crash vehicle contained two males
from spectra
a planet orbiting the star zeta to kane
and a female from one of the two
inhabited planets in the serious system
aragon the planet warrior woman
you think how does she know so much
about it
the female was me
so i have a right to ask my question
i i will now acquaint you with some of
my story in brief i am aware of purple a
top rank in the military some years ago
our president
astra asked me to come to work to check
out what was going on
i was very familiar with earth
you live here
but in fairness she does do quite a good
drawing of all the people now we don't
know her name obviously this is a
picture
she she uh she drew of herself
jillian you you didn't send this letter
did you because
this woman looks spookily like you i
think and the person sitting next to me
is
yes i'm sure in my baby grow
how long have you been married for oh
uh yeah exactly how long
exact dates please you're supposed to be
the poster child for marriage how do you
get married
[Music]
december 23 1961 so we'll be
47 years in december
it really does
[Applause]
he just keeps telling himself it's only
a movie
now she's my trophy wife and you keep
her on the shelf i know
[Music]
she keeps me honest seriously and she's
she's always been more mature and
brighter than me and so i've been smart
enough to listen to
her how do you keep the romance going
well
it just you know you get older you know
you've changed your idea of romance
changes
you don't bother that's what you're
saying no no
i'm delighted to say we bother but uh
the ideal kind of uh way to go into a
marriage is
that you'll promise that person that you
will help them become themselves
at all costs so you will tell them the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
all the time and most of the time you'll
be the only person
that will and there's another level to
it as well people talk about happiness
in this so oh i'm happy as larry or
he makes me happy she made this but they
rarely talk about
joy and that's the thing that transcends
the whole relationship
is the element of joy and and realizing
the with gratitude and praise the other
person
has allowed you to experience joy
safe to say that's the most profound
thing anyone's ever said on this show
[Applause]
i'm still a bit stuck on that be
completely honest with them at all times
i'm still i'm still like stuck on that
rapid while you've sailed on down the
river
i don't think this is gonna work
you